Robert Downey jr. has now done the iron
suit in six movies over the course of
nearly ten years whatever the actors
future maybe he really is iron man i'm
simon and this is your genius
billionaire playboy philanthropist news
update Iron Man fans were treated some
good news last week when it was
confirmed that Robert Downey jr. would
play the role again in 2017 spider-man
homecoming now the Iron Man Tony Stark
actor has said he'd be open to playing
Iron Man again in a fourth standalone
movie if it ever comes to be in a 2014
interview with variety Downey jr. said
there was no plans for a fourth iron man
film a line he repeated in other public
interviews according to slash film
however in a Nightline video feature of
a captain america civil war our DJ said
I feel like I could do one more a for
standalone iron man movie has not been
officially announced though given the
huge box office performance of the first
three films and Iron Man's enduring
appeal there is clearly a business
opportunity though you might be having
to wait a wild CIA man again in his own
film we'll be seeing a lot of Tony Stark
in the coming years Downey jr. will play
the part in the upcoming Avengers
infinity war movies and spider-man
homecoming according to box office mojo
the last iron man movie was 2013 Iron
Man 3 which made 1.2 billion dollars
globally at the box office in other
related news i am and director jon
favreau recently told comic book movie
that he can't imagine the Iron Man
series moving forward with anyone other
than Downey jr. in the lead role do you
think I a man should get another solo
outing or do you prefer watching him
punching the living daylights out of his
Super Friends let us know in the
comments below or come find me on
Twitter i'm at the jagan or thanks for
watching and for your entertainment news
keep it gamespot
you